[Music]  the police are now running back into the  capitol building  a site we've never seen before a mob of  trump's supporters stormed the u.s  capitol today  to protest the presidential election  results  that breach disrupted lawmakers who were  just beginning to count electoral votes  police put the area on lockdown and  lawmakers were evacuated from the senate  floor  later on law enforcement released tear  gas to disperse the crowd  we do thank you for joining us on 8 news  now at 5. officials say one woman who  was shot  during the incident is dead i'm brian  loftis  hi there brian and i'm denise valdez so  after four hours now we can tell you  that the capitol has been secured  and in fact the last time the capital  was breached was more than 200 years ago